how's it goin everybody it's Warren and
today we have some amazing news in
regards to the one and only Hulk
a lot of people have been wondering what
exactly does the future of the Hulk look
like in the MC we just got announced
she-hulk coming to our own Disney Plus
show but so far we've had no actual
confirmation that Mark Ruffalo's Hulk is
going to be sticking around in the MCU
despite what Kevin Feige has recently
said about there being many story arcs
for the Hulk left and a lot of people
weren't really that excited about his
arc in Avengers endgame yes he did bring
everybody back but besides that he
wasn't really that involved at least not
in the final battle when everybody
wanted to see him Hulk out and
especially get that rematch with fan OHS
but now thanks to an interview with Mark
Ruffalo the future seems a little bit
more clear but first if you enjoy Marvel
content I post Marvel videos daily and
I'm doing a giveaway for an xbox one and
a ps4 right now so be sure to subscribe
with notifications turned on like this
video and leave a comment down below to
enter the giveaway so as I just
mentioned Mark Ruffalo and Kevin Feige
have met and have talked about the
future of the Hulk in which Kevin Feige
said that there were many different
stories they have not explored yet and
this comes directly from Kevin Feige so
it's already been hinted at before that
the Hulk is not done in the MCU yet and
not to mention that when Kevin Feige
announced she-hulk he said that there is
not only one Hulk in the MCU anymore
there is now - again implying that the
Hulk is not done however we don't need
to imply any more Mark Ruffalo has
recently spoken up about his involvement
in the MCU in an interview about his
upcoming movie dark waters he was asked
about his involvement with she-hulk and
when he was asked this he immediately
began to smile and started to play a
little bit coy saying I don't know I'm
supposed to be meeting with the great
Kevin Feige the great and mysterious
Kevin Feige I'm supposed to talk to him
to see if there is some place for the
Hulk in she-hulk I don't think any
she-hulk mr. great mister Feige great
mysterious mr. foggy see if there's some
someplace and then he was asked if he
wanted to cameo in she-hulk and he said
sure why not it's been a great ride so
we have an official confirmation from
Mark Ruffalo himself him stating that he
is going to
meet with Kevin Feige to talk about the
Hulk's feature in the MCU and if he's
going to cameo and she-hulk now it's
clearly a no-brainer to put the Hulk in
she-hulk
after all in the comics she-hulk or
Jennifer Susan Walters is cousins with
Bruce Banner and the comics Jennifer
gets injured very badly and she needs a
blood transfusion from Bruce this in
turn causes her to Hulk out although
it's a different and more mild form
she's still big green and powerful but
she has her personality still so she is
basically like bro Hulk that we saw an
Avengers in game but it's kind of hard
to have a blood transfusion from the
Hulk without having the Hulk in the
series not to mention if you have
somebody introduced into the MCU that is
becoming the Hulk she's most likely
going to seek out the original Hulk and
again like I mentioned before just
before Avengers in game came out Kevin
Feige was asked about the story of the
Hulk and he said that him and Mark
Ruffalo met before Avengers in game to
talk about the story moving forward with
the Hulk and he said that Mark Ruffalo
brought many different creative ideas to
the table and so did Kevin Feige and he
said that Mark Ruffalo was very excited
to continue the character well it
definitely seems like that is what's
happening because again Mark Ruffalo has
confirmed that he will be meeting with
Kevin Feige to talk about the future of
the Hulk in the future of the Hulk in
she-hulk
and definitely don't believe that he is
just meeting with Kevin Feige to talk
about she-hulk
there has been so much talk about what
the Hulk's feature is in the MCU and
he's one of the actors and characters
much like Chris Hemsworth and Thor who
aren't done yet they're just waiting for
the next story and now we have Thor love
and thunder coming out and now it seems
like Mark Ruffalo and Kevin Feige are
going to meet to see what's next for the
Hulk
so the Hulk is going to be returning but
let me know down below if you like the
Hulk story arc in Avengers in game if he
didn't return would you be okay with his
story and Avengers in game or would you
like to see the story of the Hulk move
forward and again don't forget to
subscribe with notifications turned on
and like the video to enter my xbox one
or ps4 giveaway and Marvel infinity saga
collector's box as always thank you all
so much for watching
woof woof